معنا الان من عمان اللواء فايز الدويري
الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجيه اهلا وسهلا
بك عندما يتحدث عن ضروره فحص شامل للهياكل
الدفاعيه في كييف ما الذي يعنيه ذلك عمليا
يعني في الواقع هذه الحاله تنطبق على
جانبي الصراع الرئيس
الاوكراني تحدث صراحه واعاده تقييم
والرئيس الروسي تحدث عن محاوله احداث فتنه
داخليه وتحدث عن القوميات وبالتالي لا اجد
انسجاما وتطابقا ما بين تصريحات او
البيانات العسكريه وما بين تصريحات
السياسيين تصريحات السياسيين يمكن ان تفسر
على ان هناك فشل ولو جزئي في مضروبات
الدفاع الجوي في الجانب الاوكراني وفي
منظومات الدفاع الجوي والقوات حرس الحدود
الروسيه اذا اخذنا وتبنينا البيانات
العسكريه نجد ان نسبه النجاح في بعض
الحالات ترقى الى ميه بالميه 12 صاروخ
اسكندر تم اسقاطها 53 طائره مسيره تم
اسقاطها اذا لو كان هذا هذه البيانات
دقيقه
ويمكن البناء عليها لما تحدث الرئيس
الاوكراني عن ضروره اعاده تقييم الاداء
الفعلي لمنظومات الدفاع الجوي يقابل ذلك
ان البيانات التي تتعلق بالجانب الاخر
عندما تكون هناك هجوما داخل
او عندما تكون هناك هجمات صاروخيه على
كييف اذا ذهبنا باتجاه تصريحات الروسيه في
حال مهاجمه كيف الحديث عن اصابه بعض
المنشات العسكريه مبنى الاستخبارات اعطاب
خمسه طائرات النجاح في كذا يقابل ذلك
الجانب الاوكراني عندما نتحدث عن عمليه
بريه يتحدث عن انجازات ميدانيه كبيره
تنكرها روسيا اذا هناك حلقه مفقوده الحلقه
المفقوده تم توضيحها وتحديدها من خلال
تصريحات الزعامات ان هناك اخفاقات ميدانيه
لدى الجانبين والان كل جانب يسعى الى
تصويب مكامل الخطا وتصويب المسار
العملياتي لتقليل الخسائر والاضرار التي
تلحق من خلال القصف الذي يقوم به الجانب
الاخر كان لافتا ايضا فايز الدويري حديث
جلنسكي عن ضروره اجراء تحقيق استخبارات
شامل كما وصفه بالدول التي تساعد روسيا
سواء في الصواريخ او الطائرات المسيره
يعني الا يدري الى حد الان من يساعد روسيا
الحديث منذ بدايه استخدام الطائرات
المسيره والحديث عن جلب ذخائر مدفعيه من
كوريا الشماليه والحديث في وان كان تحت
الطاوله عن امكانيه تزويد ايران لروسيا
بصواريخ نحن كمحللين ومتابعين لدينا قطع
من المعلومات فيفترض بالجانب الروسي
الجانب الاوكراني ان يكون لديه صوره اوضح
ولكن اعتقد انه يريد ان يثبت ذلك بيع من
خلال
وثائق تدين بصوره فاضحه لانه على سبيل
المثال ايران قالت نعم زودنا النظام
الروسي بطائرات شاهد 136 قبل الحرب
ولم تكن هناك حرب الان هو يطالب بتقديم
بيانات تفصيليه في اعداد الطائرات واوقات
تسليمها فبالتالي يكون لديه الحجه لمواجهه
ايران او مواجهه اي دوله اخرى تدعم روسيا
كما ان روسيا تعمل بهذا الاتجاه من اجل
التحقق ماذا قدمت المانيا ماذا قدمت
بريطانيا الاعداد الانواع والتواريخ شكرا
جزيلا لك لواء فايز الدويري من عمان